so I want to ask both of you this film
was a long time in the making so tell me
how it went when you went to money
people and said we have this great film
about a chess player well you want to go
for it well it didn't we did go to the
money people right away it started about
11 years ago when I first went to a
couple of writers and came up with a
pitch and then we went to Tobey Maguire
and having Toby with us when we all
walked into Sony Pictures and said we
have this great idea for a movie about
it chess player what we didn't really
say that but well what did we say we
said I mean this is I don't recall
exactly what seven years ago in that
room but they were very supportive yeah
they liked this story and we're just in
on it with us and we had a you know a
bit of a journey with the development
and had to go through different steps
and a couple different right well that
was a the initial writer team and then
Stephen Knight came on so surveillance
and then Stephen Knight came on so this
studio was supportive through that whole
process of development but I think when
when we were aiming to make the film and
we were looking at what the studio
budget would have been and what kind of
film it was that's when that kind of
question arose and ultimately it just
seemed apparent even to us before we
were talking to them look we were gonna
end up taking this out of the studio and
making independently I had always
thought that the kind of sports story
would be a good way to do the film and
to have a kind of a character study
within a sports movie mmm and I I didn't
want to do
you know a biopic about Bobby that
covered his entire life but but then to
try to encapsulate a lot of what we
learned about Bobby within the structure
that we chose of the movie in that time
period was definitely a challenge and as
I learned more and more about Bobby
through you know reading things about
him and talking to people who knew him
there were so many things that I wanted
to put into the film and you know it was
difficult against the restraints of the
form and the structure of this film you
know that's just sort of the form we
chose and then I would try to pack in
anything I could that fit and Ed's ouack
our fellow producer and director you
know I would come to him with some idea
and I okay I know we can't do this
because you know we're on our schedule
don't have the set but let me tell you
it's amazing story and there were just
the story after story that I just wish I
could have put into the film little bits
in there yeah but that's what we try to
do so we would try to sort of pull the
essence of those things those stories
and you know kind of layered into what
kind of real estate that we had in in
nineteen fifty eight or nine we had Van
Cliburn Clannad Clyburn winning the Cold
War on a piano in 1980 we had the hockey
team winning it on ice and here we had
the cold war being won on a chess board
by somebody who's a pretty fragile
vessel to invest that in and I think
that came across was that important that
cold war context and subtext to tell
that story but not to make it the story
well yeah it's obviously important it
meant everything it gives it larger
meaning and it's the reason everybody
cared so much about the event in in many
ways that when I the way I used to pitch
this when I first started it was you
know in some ways he he was the worst
person to represent the United States
and and and and Boris Spassky was in
some ways the worst person to represent
the Soviet Union why Sir
oh well because he wasn't a communist he
loved the west and minoo for us I mean
he and he was he was just a gentleman he
was just a nice guy and I mean that you
know there's he was a great great player
obviously a great world champion the
question was was he enough of a killer
to to and and it's an interesting point
to play off Liev Schreiber who learned
his Russian very well and who played
this role very well who in a way you
wanted to like him but you knew he was
on the bad guys side we were supposed to
like you Bobby Fischer how difficult was
that with the two of you together to
make sure that the sympathies were
teetering but ended up falling on the
right side I don't know what the right
side is exactly but the American side of
course didn't you watch the movie yeah I
mean obviously we're playing into yeah
we're playing into that too you know to
a large degree because I don't know
that's where we live and you know it is
a pretty amazing story this kid from
Brooklyn that didn't have the kind of
support that the Russians had in in
terms of chess and so you had a kind of
a David and Goliath story there but I
liked a rooted for liev's character in
terms of if I'm looking at the movie I
was rooting for him I just was
personally satisfied when Bobby won and
I'm not quite sure you know it's some
that we've discussed that but I guess it
part of that's just in the framework of
the film and a little less about a kind
of strategy of actors from a performance
standpoint I mean certainly you know us
talking to each other to figure out the
balance of that that wasn't really a
thing
and for each of you to the degree with
which you were acquainted with Bobby
Fischer before this project how did you
change your mind about him if you did at
all well before this project I wasn't
sure what had happened to Bobby Fischer
so I remembered him as this sort of
Jewish Brook Jewish kid from Brooklyn
who sort of you know who became the
greatest player in the world and had
lost touch with what had happened to him
and it was only when I started the
project that I that I did a little
research and realized you know what had
really happened to him
so obviously I know a lot more and you
know it's a complete picture now it's
obviously very very different than it
was then I didn't know a lot about Bobby
Fischer I was generally aware of him
knew that he was a great chess player
had seen searching for Bobby Fischer
knew there was some something about his
personality that he was difficult or
something but that was about it
and so you know in doing the research
initially when Gail first talked to me
about the project that's when I learned
the kinds of horrific things that Bobby
was saying publicly and it did give me
pause at first in terms of whether or
not to get involved with the project and
and as I learned as I learned more and
more about the story I just thought it
was a really fascinating story and that
hopefully we could you know weave the
right elements together to be as
truthful as possible and hopefully make
an engaging film